headspace files with a crimp top are  typically used for gc analysis as it  provides the tightest seal creating a  leak-proof seal for even the most  volatile samples our headspace files  have a rounded flat bottom base for  maximum sample space and are universally  compatible with a broad variety of  headspace auto samplers we also carry  flat bottom headspace vials too if you  have a ctc style auto sampler either  kind of vial works you only need to be  wary of which style you choose if you  have a carousel style auto sampler it's  usually safer to just choose the rounded  flat bottom vials for all carousel style  auto samplers like the shamatsu hs20  headspace capsepta are available in ptfe  silicone for multiple injections for  your sample we offer a 200c temp  resistance septa and a 350c temp  resistance septa generally going with  the higher temp septa is good for all  applications the 200c is more cost  effective for lower temp applications